health secretary sergey javid is here
and before we start proper uh mr javid i
just want to remind our viewers of these
images that we saw towards the end of
last week
when a hospital was hit it's a maternity
hospital this is what happened
this was a lady that was being
stretchered
out of that maternity hospital i'm sure
you'll remember the images um
we believe
we were just hearing actually that
she had a cesarean section and the baby
has died and we're now also being told
that mum has died as well
remember that the russian authorities
said that it was fake news is that a war
crime
yes i think it is um it's it's an
appalling atrocity
it's a war crime because uh under
international law uh you cannot attack
health facilities hospitals
and in fact
the recent most recent information i
have from the world health organization
is they now have documented evidence of
at least 31 such attacks of health
facilities hospitals including shelling
a couple of days ago of a cancer
hospital
as well so these are war crimes today
the justice secretary will be in the
hague he'll be meeting there with the
chief prosecutor and others to offer
britain's help in helping to gather the
evidence but also with a future
prosecution of president putin and his
team
and hospitals right across the country
that have been hit
right across the country yes these
appalling atrocities and when the
british embassy the russian embassy in
britain says that it's fake news how
should we deal with that i know that
that tweet has subsequently been taken
down by twitter but nevertheless that's
the propaganda that there i mean the
only fake news is everything we hear uh
from russia i mean russia is we saw this
in in this country with the salisbury
attacks and it's continued ever since
and we can see for ourselves what's
actually happening we've seen from you
know brave sky reporters we heard just
yesterday an american journalist
was killed uh by the russians so
targeted targeted killed and
it's an opportunity for me actually to
say to thanks to all the journalists
that are out there risking their lives
bringing us the real facts and the real
news of what's actually happening on the
ground okay um
15-minute drive away from the nato
border if you will aka poland
there was an attack yesterday 35 people
died and
it's edging ever closer to a challenging
nato
what happens if there is a missile just
the other side into the nato border
look we've been very clear even before
the war started
that
if if there was a an attack on any nato
country even if a just a single toe cap
of a russian soldier steps into nato
territory
then it will be war with nato and nato
would respond and and that hasn't
changed throughout this conflict and
there would be a significant response
from nato if there was any kind of
attack from russia and we've been very
very clear from that the polish
president wants to go further than that
a polish president is saying if there is
chemical attacks
in ukraine then it's a war that nato
should get involved with what's
britain's position on that
we've been
clear about any kind of attack on nato
would be obviously unacceptable attack
in ukraine but it's a it's a chemical
attack
i'm not i'm not going to get into a
hypothetical situation about what may or
may not happen but we have been cleared
i mean and also okay to be perfectly
frank it's never helpful for us to set
out in advance what we may or we or may
not do in such a situation we wouldn't
want to
tell the enemy what what the response
might be it just wouldn't make any sense
but
our message has been very clear from the
start is that any kind of attack
anything
that touches nato territory or impacts
nato in in in in any significant way
then we would respond but we don't set
that out that kind of response in
advance and this attack um on the base i
i believe that british military
personnel have been uh housed there
previously were there any there when
this attack happened on the board i
don't know the answer to that question
okay are we still sending what sort of
arm shipments are we sending
uh we have i mean so far we have
supplied the i think probably more than
any other country uh ukraine with uh
weapons i think there's something like
3615 anti-tank weapons the so-called
sort of end-law anti-tank weapons and
they've they've helped ukraine
significantly uh so far and the defense
secretary has also said that we are
considering uh sending some other
weapons including the the star streak uh
weapon which is a anti-aircraft uh
missile system and also the javelin
anti-a anti-tank missile system okay
talk to me about these little ones that
have got cancer and have arrived in the
uk what's going on well yeah so
yesterday we received 21 very ill
ukrainian children with cancer
they these are all children innocent
children of course they've been forced
to leave their home uh because of the
russian invasion and they were all
receiving treatment in in ukraine
they'll now be cared for by our
incredible nhs staff all here in the uk
and i'm also just very grateful to
all our partners that have helped to
make this happen the polish government
in particular and of course uh the nhs
to get these children out over the
weekend uh with their families and
they're all in different parts of the uk
there's six nhs hospitals uh that will
eventually receive them and give them
the treatment uh that they need and how
long are they allowed to stay
um as long as necessary uh really and so
the in the first instance just to get
them out very quickly uh they were all
given six-month uh visas but that's
we're going to extend that to at least
three years uh but it'll be up to them
there and whilst they're here is the
children uh with their mothers in one or
two cases with carers uh some siblings
uh i think it's 49 people in total and i
just think it's it's great that we can
help in this way and we said right from
the start we will stand with the people
of ukraine and and help in any way that
we can and they can stay for
up to three years
at least yeah and and beyond that it
will be up to them to to decide you know
what they wish to do but in
the in at least for three years uh
they'll be here and uh the children in
particular get all the medical treatment
that they need okay um what about other
finally finally we're pulling our finger
out and families can come to the uk but
they have to be
families in the uk who want to offer a
home have to have the name of a
ukrainian family how's that going to
work well it will work with the
charities that we are working closely
with so there are a number of charities
especially on the ground in poland and
in moldova and met they're already
receiving these charities with the help
of those respective governments a number
of people
there are people that have already or
will certainly continue to express an
interest in coming to the uk
and through those charities through the
website that's going live later this
week they will be connected and and that
is how a host will be able to say you
know i will take a family of you of this
size you may be a mother with two or
three children and i've got enough space
uh for them and they will be connected
and put together and so cap on the
number of people that can come no
there's no there's no cap and uh and
there shouldn't be because you know we
don't know sadly where where this uh war
is going to end we've seen that there's
already millions of refugees there will
be many more uh but it's a it's an open
offer for any british family to to
extend its hand and offer shelter and
support do you acknowledge that it's
taken us too long to get to where we are
well i think it's it's been a difficult
process in in in responding to this in
in you we start we're actually one of
the first countries to offer
humanitarian support over 400 million
pounds of support so far i think more
bilaterally than any other country
we've offered we've talked about the
weapons and the military support
for my part in my department as well as
what we've just talked about about
helping these children we've already
sent seven flights of vital medicines
medical equipment medical supplies i
think i've got another one uh leaving
today we've done more in terms of
medical supplies in any country so i
think collectively we are doing a huge
amount as a country to help but it's
right that we do britain's are you know
that they will open their doors to
people if they possibly can and there
will be lots of barriers put in their
way up until now and thankfully it's
coming into place now all i'm saying is
do you acknowledge that potentially that
should have happened earlier look i i i
we all i think everyone would have want
to see the
help to ukrainian refugees as much as we
can as quickly as we can but it's also
worth saying as a country we do have a
very proud record
of offering sanctuary to people fleeing
conflict and war
with the thousands of syrians and
afghans that have been resettled with
the support for over a hundred thousand
uh hong kong nationals that have applied
under the scheme that the prime minister
set out last year and and then again
with ukraine we will absolutely play our
part and and make sure we are
giving refuge to those that need it
quicker couldn't it well it's happening
it's happening now um the prima we also
know that the prime minister is heading
to saudi arabia over the next day or so
to talk about oil it's a big challenge
given
the sanctions against russia
saudi arabia executed 81 people over the
weekend
are we turning a blind eye to the
world's evils in order to get enough oil
to keep the lights on look we we have a
long-standing relationship with saudi
arabia and i can certainly tell you in
the time that i've been in government
under three prime ministers we've always
had a very candid and frank relationship
with uh saudi arabia where
wherever there are human rights issues
we've raised them with them and we can
do that because we have this
relationship but we also have an
economic relationship with saudi arabia
we're not dependent uh directly as a
country on their oil but
your energy prices and access to energy
is a huge important issue so i'm pleased
that we can have this relationship with
saudi arabia where we can talk about the
human rights issues as well as there are
longer term do we have to worry about
those to do business with a country that
chops people's heads off
well look we as i said we've got a
candid frank relationship with them it's
it's a very important country uh for us
and i think it is right the the prime
minister is leading this effort to
engage saudi arabia even more so in in
the events that we're seeing unfolding
now talk to me about um lebrodev um if
you would please lord labvidev um you
tweeted in august 2020 that lebron is a
first generation immigrant britain can
be very proud of do you still think that
um
well i
yes well i think here we can be proud of
people that have settled in the uk and
helped build british businesses and
given in support for many charities and
good causes
i've got no reason to to to doubt
anything that i've said there but
obviously you're asking me this because
of the recent
reporting around
lebedev uh receiving a a peerage and
anyone who receives a peerage in in the
uk they all have to be vetted by the
house of lords nominations commission
and in this case it's no different yeah
but if the security service you say is
the security risk the prime minister
keeps pushing and pushing and pushing
and saying no i want him to be a lord
surely if our security services who are
the best in the world say
i don't think so he may well be a
security risk surely we should take
notice of that well first of all i agree
that our security services are the best
in the world i've had the privilege to
work with them uh for many years uh and
and and it is right third for the house
of lords nomination commission if they
need to seek information from any other
part of the the uk the authorities then
they should do so they should then use
knighthood no but then they should take
that into account
and and
the nomination commission should take
that into account and then complete this
vetting process and that's exactly
what's happened here and you're
comfortable with him keeping his
lordship yes i am okay final we're
almost out of time i just want to ask
you about delta cron and stealth omicron
where are we with all of that
well the we keep the situation very
carefully under review
there's no other variant of concern out
there that that
is an issue at this point in time we
have seen some rises in infections of
the last week but given the increase in
social mixing this was to be expected so
the situation at the moment is stable
no there's no particular concern at this
point in time okay thank you for joining
us on the program appreciated thank you